The other thing that we
discussed in the last lecture
was a classification of the
different states of the Markov
chain into different types.
A Markov chain in
general has states
that are recurrent, which means
that from that recurrent state,
you can go somewhere else and
then from that somewhere else
you can always come back to it.
So if you have a Markov
chain of this form
and you start in state
nine, the options for you
is to either go to state
three or to state five.
But no matter what,
if you go to three,
you can come back always,
and if you go to five,
you can always
come back as well.
So clearly nine here would be
a recurrent state, and three
for the same reason,
and five as well.
Now, if you look at
the state six or seven,
it is the same thing.
Starting from six, the
only way that you can go to
is to either stay at six or go
to seven, and then in that case
you always come back.
And same thing from seven,
you can either go to six
and that's it's,
actually, and come back.
So both of these are
recurrent as well.
So in a case the state
is not recurrent,
we will call it transient.
So let's look at for
example state one.
From state one, if you go from
one to two and then go to six,
there is no way to
come back to one.
So the state 1 is transient,
and for the same reason
the state four
will be transient,
and the state 2
will be transient.
What about eight?
Well, the same reason, the
state is transient as well.
So what we have seen also is
the notion of a recurrent class.
A recurrent class is,
again, a collection
of recurrent states that can
communicate between each other.
So here, for this specific
example, we have two classes.
This is one class, right,
so it's a class one.
Let's call it
recurrent class one.
And this is a recurrent
class, recurrent class two.
So here again we have two
classes instead of one,
because if you are in
one of these classes,
there is no way that you can
find a path to go to one state
here and vice versa.
If you are in one of
these states here,
there is no path that would lead
you to that recurrent class.
In the case where you have two
recurrent classes, like here
or more, it is pretty
clear that in the long run,
the steady state behavior
of the Markov chain
will really depend
on where you started.
So for example, if
your Markov chain
started in that recurrent
class, there is no probability
that in the long run it will be
in that class, and vice versa.
If it started here,
the probability
of being in that recurrent
class in the long run is zero.
So the long run behavior
of the Markov chain
will depend on the
initial condition.
In the case where you have
only one recurrent class,
let's forget about that
portion, for example,
and you have only
that portion here.
Then maybe the initial
condition will not
matter in the long
run, but in fact it's
not going to be always
the case, depending
on the recurrent
class being periodic
or not as we will
see in the next clip.